which is even more ah
[Music]
sometimes when you're struggling you
need to go higher
guys barry's no longer around us what do
you think of his music i mean he thinks
so deep that i thought of your heart but
he
[Music]
is probably one of the strongest things
in judaism where your brain and that's
where amunda starts and it's actually
quite a big deal
so what pushes you to do something that
is bigger than you he can either help
you or destroy you
they used to call me manny fresh back in
the day
once you go up you never come back is
that what happens here he's going
in going in
what are we getting into here okay so as
i mentioned to you in
other videos the hasidic world has it
has its own ecosystem
so we told you we have our own media we
have our own food we have
everything so there's also a big music
scene and it's actually quite a big deal
we have hasidic music uh stars who are
getting
millions of views on their music videos
and and a lot of them
you know can rank on the charts on
spotify what kind of music
so there's hasidic music there's a
little bit of hasidic pop music
a lot of it is about is about connecting
to god through music
there's also a little bit of
entertainment aspect you're gonna learn
all about it and we're gonna take you to
some of the hasidic music
scenes biggest stars okay cool let's do
this yeah
so is this one of your favorite
musicians this is uh someone who i
really enjoy listening to and his
this is uh he actually you know by night
he's a performer by day
he helps out but he started a school for
for kids who don't necessarily fit into
the regular
um acidic high school system okay so
we're gonna go meet him and some
students and see what they
what they say all right hello
you look like a musician where's betty
it's okay if i roll the uh
the camera all right cool you're all
musicians yeah what do you play
i sing what do you do you're in sales
you sell music nope what do you sell
home
once you go up you never come back is
that what happens here
you stay in this place no no once you
enter this place you don't want to go
once you're out you're in mentally
you're never you're you don't want to
leave yeah all right we're going in
we're going in you're in
help really don't know uh completely
what's happening here
which keeps it exciting that's what
spending time with shalomi is never
really knowing what you're getting into
down here
hello hello good to meet you your
handshake or your hog
already fist bumps whatever you want
i'll give you a hug peter
your name barry barry mary webber i
should thank you
more of a yeah
did you paint this i did not it's very
uh
mystical right right so this is a good
room to think
most of the people that are here just
come out of the goodwill
and help you know they volunteer
yeah this is my office also one of my
students
he's the salesman yeah he sells kitchens
okay so this is where the boys are at
for the day
there's an amazing yeah
[Music]
okay well so who met this that this rule
is
hi peter hello hi hi how are you danny
benny nice to meet you maddie's from the
hood
minnie's from the hood they used to call
me manny fresh back in the day
manny fresh
[Music]
so um i'm going actually in that room
okay but i'm using it now for a zoom
that i'm gonna do for organization
i'm gonna sing two songs for them a
friend of mine that has organization and
he asked me
if i can they're having like a weekend
retreat uh-huh
something about you know growth and
in a muna which means belief
a moon is actually a very interesting
topic emunah is is probably one of the
strongest things in judaism
it's basically a concept that is against
all odds it's basically where you're
where your brain ends that's where muna
starts it's basically believing is
something that doesn't exist
like faith like like even aliens is
something that you
you know it's it's a good feeling but
the you know
as long as you don't have proof you call
it a moon you have a moon and aliens so
a godly thing is something that is very
beyond us and the only connection that
we have is through our
deeds that we do so mola could be looked
at as your life path in a way too
is pushing yourself to a place of course
in a positive way
or believing in god or believing in
anything good
believing anything good that will happen
although
you don't see any signs leading you to
that thing it's just
it's just basically telling your brain
that this is what i want to believe in
amuna did that help you with your music
it helps
of course yeah did it guide you or you
are a musician since day one i mean
nobody can foresee things
yeah so what pushes you to do something
that is bigger than you
uh what jesus is believe
you believe in yourself you believe in
in the world you believe in your
community you believe in god you believe
in something higher
so in the hasidic faith it's all about
this believing in the self first correct
before you can give to others
yeah if you don't if you don't have the
concept of believing in yourself
you're a vessel you're a vessel to
everything so if you don't have love
you don't know what love is you can't
love you can't love god if you don't
love
people if you don't love yourself you
feel like you're doing your
your divine mission right now you're the
conduit something's coming through you
every every human being is that but most
don't find it
well most people don't think about it
too much and they don't
they don't have the awareness but i
think this
judaism is all about awareness so uh
yeah that's that's definitely a very
spiritual mission that i have with my
singing
i see people that are not very happy and
music just makes them in a good mood it
opens their hearts
you know opening their hearts is where
you start feeling yourself you know most
people who are
controlled by by robotics say in the
future robotics are going to control us
this is basically controlling our
feelings and our minds
it's telling us our schedule what to buy
and where to go
and what to be influenced by but you
yourself who are you
are you that robot so yeah but without
this
we can't bring our moon out in this day
and age right like
this this can either help you or destroy
you
so you got to be aware of it so it's
discipline right would you say that
discipline is what gets you to the place
barry
a couple maybe you will want me to share
this but a couple was a year ago half a
year ago he got rid of the smartphone
and now he got himself a flip phone he
doesn't want to distract anything this
is his phone fantastic this is my phone
i find it very
helpful in business i just have more
time for myself
um i'm more scheduled that i'm not being
very simple this is a robot that is
controlling people
but you're a very famous musician right
so you need to use social media so
you have to i i only keep this where i
need it
like if whether it's work related or
yeah usually i'll take it along at a gig
so i have my lyrics
and i have certain hours that i take in
my office and i do my emails and so on
but just when i walk in the store in the
grocery when i walk in the streets
i'm not just like that it just you know
keeps me alive and it looks like very
primitive
i like it but i would i would like to
get to that level
yeah i i think it's i think it's an
improvement i just i don't have the
discipline yet
a lot of my a lot of my friends that are
big businessmen they they also
you know do it that way hasidum is the
it's very conservative form of judaism i
would have thought
music would be an interference with
god's
voice or message right so if you go to
you know islam
the most conservatives are not going to
listen to any music right
so how does that work but in islam there
are certain types of singing like
we would
yeah the call of prayer is something
that is very musical i love i love
listening to it whenever i'm
in you know any muslim area and you know
they're allowing the speakers to put it
on i
i love it so how does it work in his
sedum
the spirituality of it is very
interconnected with mysticism
which involves a lot of doing things
that are technically based on a
meditational
idea and one of that is singing
[Music]
during the week during the week it'll be
this is the organization calling me
hello
okay let's hold on to these precious
moments
and the second
um barry weber is with us and this is
something
unbelievable i i personally love your
music so much and for the fact that
you're with us
hi yes give me a favor you were at my
niece's wedding you played
and if you give me 10 minutes i'm going
to find the huss in the car and get one
of my daughters to get married
to get you on zoom and i can fill up the
wedding right now for the right price
[Laughter]
you're making a deal before i'm
breathing thank you first of all for
having me
uh this is a great great mission that
you guys are
you know belief is something that takes
us beyond all boundaries
and we have the tool of the muna which
is believing in yourself all the good
that we have is not because we deserve
it
it's mainly because you know this is
destined to us
because god is a giver you know he loves
us he
and and the world is beautiful the world
could have been black and white and he
gave us color
and he gave us meaning and so on we got
to look for that
background one of my students
[Music]
loyalty
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
truly brings us to a munna because a
moon has something believing is
something that we haven't witnessed in
the past
it's it's something that we really want
to achieve but the only way we can
achieve it is by just
throwing out positive thoughts that this
thing could happen regardless if it
makes sense or not
thank you so much so much thank you
have a beautiful day thank you so much i
want to show you
uh we have a whole section of animals
that
we care for okay uh there's actually
injured animals
so i just want to point out that he
could have charged like two thousand
dollars for that zoom call i don't know
what
i don't know what his going rate is but
it's way higher than that for for an
event
yeah and he does this kind of thing all
the time like in in hasidic
judaism as we mentioned it's all about
kindness he goes
probably on a daily basis but if not
definitely a couple times a week go to
the hospitals
sings for people who are sick it's all
about kindness if there are sick
children and people who we can improve
their lives just by singing we'll
take out of our time and know that
there's
multiple organizations that you know
organize
and that's that's actually how it
started here who are the canadian kids
you were singing to jose
these are this is organization of women
okay it's an organization of women
like a retreat of women that uh went
through certain
uh um i'm not gonna
share because he's just sure there
obviously they needed you know my
encouragement
my physique that they call and uh i was
glad to do that it's just a zoom call
it's a half hour of my time and i i'm
sure i helped hundreds
the other whatever we couldn't see their
faces but that's what it is is
your audience bigger here or in israel
it's bigger here
okay um there's a big audience in
south america in chile there's like yeah
70
of my messages that i get like in social
medias and platforms are from people who
speak spanish
i can never reply they're they're all
they're all hasidic
no not only jews huh yeah
a lot of non-jews don't listen to my
music another thing i want to point out
is that
in the secular world you have like all
these celebrities who
are probably in it for the money and the
fame and they do charitable work to be
like relatable
yeah like you know so people just think
they're still human and they're good and
i'm sure a lot of them are good people
but a lot of the aspects and it's easier
to see that the charity that's being
done
is not necessarily to help it's more to
help themselves sure
here in the city community i mean you
see very this entire day
is spent here at the school and then he
goes to sing for kids he does these zoom
calls and all the other superstars
and your name's not on the house yeah i
wouldn't i wouldn't i wouldn't allow my
name on the house you know what i mean
but like what you're saying a lot of
people do charity to get right
image and uh there's two types it's very
impressive he
like he he's working every night till
one or two a.m he could easily oh i came
i came home last night from uh liquid
four o'clock
no he's here early in the morning with
the with the kids uh the fundraiser
event
um what what um can we walk out here
barry what's the hasidic music scene
like these days
and what genre are you in what what
would you say what john general is
hasidic music
okay i know it's not on the itunes
charts but um
we usually fit in pop for popular music
but
um it's it's a mix barry
is is probably the number one hasidic
music star for
for reggae he does reggae very well yeah
oh really of some of my own compositions
i just felt
i'm a very hard guy mm-hmm and i just
i felt that reggae resembles the
heartbeat like
yeah and so um you know that i play uh
guitar which is also something you keep
on your heart
you know most of these are rescued down
animals uh people who
you know started off having little pets
and then you know
they couldn't deal with it we have a
whole section i'll show you of roosters
many people take
roosters and they realize that the wake
they
wakes up their neighbors uh-huh and they
have to just let it go so sure
and these these are these can be
sometimes vicious you know they fight
right right
and we have to build them individual
cages and the boys
you know they build a care for them
he's boss in this section
this guy he feeds them every day hello
he's caring very caring
boy if you go close
or just run because they you know they
were they were abused
disease how do people uh abuse
roosters because it makes goes on their
nerves
so they neglect them and they like
torture like so so they come here
we start feeding them caring for them
and then eventually we let them out
here and so so for you guys this is like
a place to chill hang out play music
like a family sort of it's a family yeah
we feel like a family we're so close to
each other like
like a real family guys barry's no
longer around us what do you think of
his music
it's amazing it's something unique
something professional it's good it's
professional music he's the he's the
jewish justin bieber
black is jewish justin bieber yeah he
says that's a compliment his songs
he sings so deep that i thought is your
heart his voice is incredible it's like
an amazing
relaxing listen to his music it's very
calming
what i'm trying to say that he has all
kind of music for every mode
you walk into the woods um you listen to
one song
okay like for every meditation for yes
pop hip-hop
whatever does he have like your super
angry mode
you want to like just let it out let it
out
of course that's all kind of music he's
got regular relaxing music
so you guys love hanging around here
yeah i love it i never enjoyed it place
is amazing
like a school or anything everything
that came forth and now it's just
it's free for you you could take it or
leave it and everybody chose to take it
yes i own well
music is the one thing that kicks me
down when
i listen to music the whole thing
changes it chills you out
are you a rebel like i listen to certain
styles when
in certain moods every mode i hear a
are you a rebel actually we call
ourselves our lovely rebels we have to
do what's up
the school calls our lovely rebels our
lovely rebels
okay yep all right guys i'm going to
look out for you
all right
all right this is my this is my fancy
geek suit
so i usually don't ride along with it
but
so barry just said let's go for a
four-wheeler ride and
he's full of surprises got a lot going
on
i'll show you one of the one of the
places here
where it's very good for meditation it's
a part of uh
part of my daily schedule look at this
place
this is where i sit down over here just
get my
thoughts clear is this where you come up
with a lot of your inspiration for your
music my songs i
when i compose i need just the space
and this is where i do it gotcha all
right barry thanks for showing us around
all right where can people find you if
they don't already know you
well my music is streaming basically on
itunes
uh spotify all these all right guys i'll
leave barry's links down below
thank you very that was fun appreciate
it
continue on garden state parkway for
five miles
for a second
benny what's your last name friedman
friedman okay
free or freed freed fried okay free
spilled
here with benny friedman and benny
is a a producer and a performer of
acidic music
correct something like that okay okay
and so tell us what is
what is different about hasidic music or
what can you tell us
about your craft it's it's very happy
[Music]
for the most part okay um some of it's
also very sad
you try to use music as a way to bring
you
somewhere where you can't otherwise get
without it okay
can you sing us something yeah
what's your favorite jewish song
gee let me think um
bob dylan what are you learning now from
your music
sometimes when you're struggling you
need to go
higher instead of you need to do more
instead of less
how's that it's a it's just a technical
thing in singing
okay when i found myself singing a song
and struggling to sing it properly
the natural instinct is to say oh but
i'm seeing it a little too high
let me bring the key down okay when in
fact
if you i was struggling in the it's
called the bridge
and if you bring it up and just pop just
a little bit higher than that
tough point everything opens up
is that a metaphor for life yes i think
so i mean i'm not the philosopher
but that's what i was going for when
things are difficult
don't try to do less try to do more like
uh
like we say if you have a
an obstacle so you can try to go around
it you can try to go under it
but they say
first thing to do before you try all the
other easy ways
right away go over the obstacle go right
over it
so even as you've been doing this for 12
years you're a professional this is your
career
do you get these obstacles still oh yeah
benny so you're saying
you come to these hard points you come
to these hard points
and you're saying don't give up and go
down but go up so can you
can you show what you mean by that going
up oh boy
that high spot we're all looking for
anime
you know where he does instead of
belting it out where it would be a
little bit more difficult
it's called half voice
[Music]
[Music]
oh
a lot of overcoming in that you think so
yeah i felt it coming up onto a peak
thank you thank you enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh